hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
unconventional qc
implementing appropriate qc design
strategies in your lab
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by technopass clinical diagnostics
usa
to learn more visit
technopathclinicaldiagnostics.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
stan westgard director
client services and technology at
westgard quality control
then you may now begin your presentation
thank you very much welcome to all of
you i'm glad that you can join us
today i'm very happy that lab roots and
technopaths
can
bring us together on this occasion
the goal of today is to be
unconventional
and we're going to talk about
what
the habits are the common practices are
in quality control
and
how many of them are
really detrimental
and i hope that by the end of this
session you'll start to re-examine what
you are doing currently for qc
and think about
actually trying to design qc
not just
doing the same thing that you've been
doing
for a long
period of years
and i hope i'll be able to show you the
benefits of changing how you do qc
and changing your design strategy for
each test
the benefits will come
because we'll choose different rules
and we'll choose rules that help you
minimize the false rejection
and
maximize the error detection
i do of course want to again
give you the standard disclosure
technopath is making uh
making this happen today
they are compensating me for my time
i also want to do a little shout out
part of this presentation i'll be
calling out different sections of a new
workbook
that's available for free from
technopath and it's about advanced
applications in quality control
and not only can you get
educational credit from listening to
this session
if you download the workbook you'll be
able to
proceed through it and there's an
exercise at the end and you'll be able
to get
educational credit from the workbook so
you can double dip here on your
educational credits
now there's a more important disclosure
that i'm required to make by my boss
and this is particularly important
because you're only hearing my voice and
not seeing me
and so some of you
may be confused you may be thinking
you're actually talking to the rule
father or as i
as i call him the westgard
i am only a west guard
you're only listening to stan westgard
not the westgard which of course is
james westgard
and uh i've only been doing this for a
quarter of a century whereas
the westgard the rule father he's been
doing it for more than 50 years
another resource that's available to you
and really is the flagship of the
westgard efforts
is westgard.com
we have more than 70 000
laboratory professional members it's a
free membership and we give you access
to more than 600 articles
and downloads
and graphing tools
all kinds of resources about quality
control
so let's start with our first poll
we're going to talk about whether you
have been
actively managing your qc costs
so here we are have you in the past 10
years
reduced your qc frequency
have you widened the control limits you
are using
have you changed any of your qc rules
have you consolidated your qc that is
you're using fewer qc
vials than you were
in previous times or
is your qc essentially the same setting
as it was
10 years ago or 20 years ago or 30 years
ago
your qc is really going on autopilot
and we're gonna let uh
we're gonna let this uh
percolate and you can
take a moment to answer the questions uh
one of the things we'll be doing during
this session is not only are we polling
you
but we're comparing with an ongoing
survey that westgard has been westgard
and technopath have been conducting for
the past several months to really give
us a snapshot of what's going on in the
whole world
and we'll let this go
another few more
seconds
you can see
we still have people
coming in
and changed qc rules seem to be leading
and i have to say that's gratifying i am
glad to hear that people are changing
their qc rules
it means
you are the right audience you are being
less conventional
you are
embracing and uh
modifying your qc rules
and wow i'm glad to see we have so many
participants today
i think once we
get around
all right well we're going to
call it at this point say this is about
our plateau and we see
uh most of you well 35 percent of you
and that's the plurality have changed qc
rules
and now let's take a look at the current
global survey that we're running and we
have more than 500 labs in more than 100
different countries
and here the finding is
not so many people have changed qc rules
less than 10 percent and almost
two-thirds of labs say they haven't made
any
any changes in how they do qc
and that of course is a problem because
there's so many changes
in
laboratories today if you're not
keeping your qc design up to date with
your technology
you're probably
over cue seeing or in some cases you
might be under cue seeing what you're
doing
and let's remember that
the control system has been a dynamic
uh
it has been dynamic it has been changing
over the years we used to have single
analyte controls now we're at
multi-analyte
we used to have controls that were
really only targeting one level now we
have
multi-level trying to hit medically
important levels and trying to span as
much as possible the analytical
measurement range
we used to have very short life on our
controls and now we in biochemistry we
might have several years of life
and we also see an increase in the open
vial stability
that is not only is it good on the shelf
it's good when it's open
these are all things that have changed
over the years
and
that means we can make other changes
today
the things that are we see in the future
of controls is we want them to be more
commutable
and have fewer matrix effects
unfortunately
um
that runs into the efficiency
the less
the fewer preservatives and stabilizers
we put in that directly will reduce our
shelf life
could reduce how many analytes we can
put in a single control
so
we will
probably not get to a place where
everything is a is purely commutable and
there are no matrix effects
as long as our goal is we want things to
last a long time on the shelf we want
scores of analytes in a single bottle
that will require
more preserves preservatives and more
stabilizers and might make it might keep
it less communable
beyond the selection and sort of the
makeup of the controls
there is the qc rules themselves um
and that of course is right in our
wheelhouse at westgard we talk about qc
and here's our second poll and this is
going to be about your use of two sd
control limits
do you use two sd control limits and how
much do you use them
are you using them on all of your tests
are you using them on some of your tests
are you using them not at all they're
not on any of your tests at all
and you know the the history of the two
sd control limits
goes back to the dawn of the laboratory
era
back when people were using flame
photometers
when you were manually pipetting or you
were pipetting by mouth
when your volume was in the dozens your
menu was in you know your menu was
equally small
two sd limits were alive and well that
was the only way to do qc
and we see yes uh looks like a lot of
people are using on all of their tests
two sd control limits
and we seem to have plateaued now we
have a little over 200 people on the on
the webinar welcome great to have you
here
and we see yes
almost 60 percent of labs are using two
sd control limits on
all the tests
that is the conventional approach
and now we can compare ourselves
to the global
climate where 56
of labs worldwide are using qc rules the
2sd control practice
and that's half a century old
but the reason we stick with 2sd limits
you know it's more of a tradition than a
science
and a very small percentage are not
using two sd limits at all
the thing we know about two sd limits is
if you run two controls the expected
false rejection rate is nine percent
and if you run three controls
that expected false rejection rate rises
to four fourteen percent
now if you want one out of ten
or more runs
to be out of control
um that's your choice however it's uh
it's
going to be
filling your day with a lot of out of
control events
50 years ago there weren't that many
tests the runs were small the menu was
small so if you had one out of 10 runs
out of control it was something you
could manage
but we have a huge volume of tests we
have a huge menu
we have more and more instruments
to have a 10 failure rate or higher on
our on our qc process
that's really
delete
deletorious
it's uh consuming quite a bit of our
time
on waste
because again this is a false rejection
there's nothing wrong with the system
but the way you've chosen your limits
means you're actually creating problems
for yourself
now we're gonna give you our last this
is our last live poll
and this is going to be about your
westgard rules
how many of you are using westgard rules
and how much
are you using them on all of your tests
are you using them only on some of your
tests or no
you don't use westgard rules at all
and there should be kind of a difference
that we see
between the use of 2sd and the use of
westgard rules
if you recall the westgard rules were
created as a
replacement for the 2sd as a way to
improve
your qc detection
without
increasing your false rejection so try
to find that sweet spot where you have
good error detection and low false
rejection
now it looks like we're almost
plateauing here
about 200
229 230 and we saying two-thirds of labs
are saying they use westgard rules on
all of your tests
and that
can be quite flattering i i will tell uh
the rule father my boss that
west guard rules appear to be all quite
strongly alive and well here in the
second decade of the 21st century
now let's compare what we see around the
world
87 percent of labs report they are using
westgard rules and that's split between
on some tests and all tests but if you
look
at
all my tests it's about the exactly the
same so
you can see that around
60 60 to 66 percent not only in this
audience but around the world are using
westgard rules
and less than 10 percent of labs don't
use them at all
so it's a good tool
but
if you're using all the westgard rules
on all your tests
that might be overkill that might be too
many westgard rules
and
we're at a stage where we need to think
about when we should use westgard rules
and how many of them
and
we don't just we should not just use
westgard rules as a default
we want to use westgard rules when they
are necessary
but not when
they're unnecessary and of course then
the question arises well how do you know
when you need westgard rules
that's going to bring us to the next
stage
where we talk about six sigma
and more advanced techniques
if we're willing to invest a little bit
of time
in learning
sigma metrics or six sigma benchmarking
we can figure out how to do our westgard
rules
when we need them and how many of them
we need
so you may be familiar with the
traditional westgard rules but these are
the quote-unquote new westgard rules
this is what we call the westgard sigma
rules
that is we take the power of six sigma
and that benchmarking
technique and we merge it with the
westgard rules
and you can see below
the traditional westgard rules flowchart
you see the six sigma and then the five
sigma and the four sigma and the three
sigma and that's actually carving up the
westgard rules into different sections
and if you do six sigma then you only
have to do one westgard rule
and we'll discuss how many rules are
necessary based on the different sigma
categories
now one of the questions we asked
as you were registering was what do you
do when there's an out of control flag
do you repeat the control do you
run a new control do you recalibrate
do you troubleshoot and take corrective
action
your answers were
72 percent of you
repeat the control
this is the conventional approach you
have something that goes out
you run it again you repeat the control
i like to call that double or nothing qc
you're trying it you're rolling the dice
again to see if the value falls in and
you're hoping that it will
and that way you can move on with your
day
and about a quarter of you do something
different which is either you run a new
control or you try to recalibrate or
perform some maintenance
now if we go back just a little bit in
the presentation remember
a lot of you are using
two sd control limits
two sd control limits cause what
false rejections
how do you respond to a false rejection
if you're constantly hearing these
alarms going off
you don't respond to each alarm like
it's a true fighter you start to think
um
do i smell the smoke
somebody go out in the hall do you see
any smoke if not
let's just keep going
so the fact that we may be choosing two
sd control limits that corrupts our our
response
to the outliers and we're tempted to do
this repeat qc
because we're dealing with so many false
alarms
and this matches up
pretty close
to what we see globally
we see 67 percent of labs worldwide are
repeating the control
uh three-quarters say they also will
troubleshoot and find the root cause
that's you know most labs being willing
to say uh well we know we what we should
do is troubleshoot and find the root
cause
and then we had an additional four
percent say they will repeat the control
just as many times as necessary until it
falls back in
that is some some labs will repeat
not only once but twice but three times
maybe a dozen times whatever it takes to
get back in
occasionally when you
put out a survey like this you get the
unvarnished truth
and of course when we think about all
these repeats
that's not saving us money that's
burning money
it's great for your qc vendors it's
great for your manufacturers your
diagnostic manufacturers because you're
burning more product up you're burning
more reagent you're using more supplies
you're running more controls that makes
everybody but the laboratory
more profitable
if you're looking for a way a low
low hanging fruit on saving money
try to figure out how you could reduce
the number of times that you're
repeating controls and troubleshooting
again that will bring us
to this westgard sigma rules
the westgard rules themselves of course
reduce your false rejection rate but if
we use fewer westgard rules that means
our
rejection rate our false rejection rate
goes down even further
i've mentioned six sigma now of course i
want
to run through just a few of the
concepts of six sigma
and explain how this benchmarking will
bring us
to lower costs and better qc
six sigma is really the goal
and it
essentially it's a simple way to say we
we have a process where we've reduced
the number of defects
to less than four out of a million
so if you want to have
fewer than four
rejected runs out of a million
reportables
you want six sigma
and when general electric ge and
motorola
started this six sigma movement back in
the 90s
they found when they could get their
processes to six sigma
they had the highest efficiency
they had the happiest customers because
obviously they have the most reliable
um
result
and they also achieved their maximum
profitability
you want to talk about some six sigma
processes in the real world you think
about well
airline safety now you have to go back
before the pandemic remember when we
used to fly all the time well
in the u.s
less than three crashes per million
departures
better than six sigma quality
a little bit more mundane but more
relevant to the laboratory in a european
survey of pre-analytical errors they
found
the number of samples that were being
damaged in transport and the number of
samples that were not being stored
properly before analysis that was
those errors were having so low that
they had achieved six sigma so it's not
just that you're looking for six sigma
in your analytical assay but even in
your pre-analytical processes and
post-analytical processes
five sigma is good but we start to see
errors 233 per million reportables
and this is closer to how many times is
a specimen being misidentified
how many requests are being
misidentified
of course this is assuming you have an
electronic system to capture
the orders and process the tests
four sigma is where
we start to actually experience and
we're aware that the but the process has
errors we're now at above 6 000 defects
per million reportables and this is
closer to how often your luggage does
not take the same vacation as you
so remember
airlines are very safe but there is a
lost luggage baggage office
in every airport and that's because it
happens it happens often
another
common four sigma process is does the
sample come in without enough volume to
run all the tests that have been ordered
does the sample come in and it's
hemolyzed
everybody knows that is a constant
problem it's a four sigma
process
three sigma is where
the theory says that's your minimum
acceptable quality now we're at 67 000
defects per million
and now we're closer to the the com the
contaminated microbiology samples again
people know that's a chronic issue
and we have some papers
just this year that have noticed
the laboratories under the current
stress of the pandemic their
pre-analytical error rates are rising
not again it shouldn't be a real
surprise that we see we put so much
stress
we have laboratories operating
you know all shifts with
uh
employees having to do overtime not for
a short period of time but just for a
marathon
that stress creates fractures
we start to see errors go up
and then finally we have the one and two
sigma processes
this is what
theory tells us is unacceptable now
we're in the hundreds of thousands of
errors
and now we're closer to things like
departure delays for the us airline
industry
doesn't matter how
safe you are it doesn't matter how well
they handle your luggage sometimes you
just don't get to take off
and if you ever had the frustration with
your airlines you know now well what
what is below six three sigma feel like
and then you know one flight footnote we
know the fairness trial is beginning or
i should say that the
trial of elizabeth holmes the former
head
of theranos and
what's one reason
why her nine billion dollar
evaluated
company went to zero dollar valuation
because most theranos assays were below
one sigma
so now we understand a little bit about
the different positions on this six
sigma scale
the next thing we need to do is to put
ourselves on that scale with our tests
where do they fall are they six sigma
are they three sigma are they one sigma
the first step in figuring that out is
to get a performance specification or a
quality requirement
and
for those of you in the us it's pretty
simple you go with the clia regulations
because
the federal government cms is directly
regulating how good you need to be
and for
non-regulated assays you go to the
proficiency testing providers like cap
or api they will
fill in the goals that aren't directly
regulated by clia
and outside the us there's the rcpa for
australians they're really back for
germans
there's a biologic variation database
known as the ricoh's goals that's on our
website there's a more updated
database hosted by the eslm
and almost all the resources you see
here
we make available on the westgard
website for free
those tell you how good your tests need
to be
in order to understand
how good you actually are so you have a
target are you hitting the target
well for that you need two more pieces
of information you need your cv and your
bias and you need to capture this at
your most important medical decision
level
so you have your cv from your controls
and you have your bias from a number of
different possible sources it could be
from your proficiency testing
it could be you're lucky enough to have
a reference method or reference material
handy
it could be that you are using a peer
comparison software program
that
is one program that we encourage because
it gives you
a lot of data and it's readily at hand
and that allows you to determine your
bias once you know your cv and bias and
again you've been collecting this data
all the time since the lab opened the
opened its doors you've been collecting
cv and bias so really the only piece of
information that may be a little bit new
to you is that total allowable error or
performance specification
and once you have those three items
you can do a sigma metric and it's a
calculation where you take the allowable
total error that's your quality
requirement you subtract the absolute
value of the bias and then you divide by
cv
so it's your
quality goal minus your inaccuracy
divided by your imprecision
and the graph below the the graphic
below is just to give you an idea of how
the equation works
think of that allowable total error as
your tolerance limits
that's where you're supposed to keep all
your results inside of
you see that true value in the center
that's the clinical truth but
what's really going on with the patient
you want to get that but if you can keep
the result within the allowable total
error on either side
you get an answer that may not be
perfect but it's close enough to make
the right diagnosis and give the patient
the right treatment
when we
inject our bias in our cv however the
bias shifts our distribution away from
that true result
and the cv spreads out our distribution
of results so
when this bias and the cv are combined
we have a shift we have a spread our
curve
is different
and where that curve goes outside that
allowable total layer those are where
the defects occur
to make it a little more concrete let's
take a quick example
we have three levels of cholesterol
qc this happens to be from a 2014
clinical chemistry study
clia directly regulates cholesterol you
have to be good within 10 percent
so if you're running three levels of
control you have cvs at three different
levels
and if you
have a peer group program or in this
case you had a reference method it's
cholesterol we know we have a reference
network we can determine
our bias at the same three levels where
we're running our controls to determine
cv
and so in this case we have three
different possible sigma metrics
at the low end 10 minus a bias of 3
divided by imprecision of 1
is better than 6 sigma
in the middle of the range 10 minus the
bias of two and a half divided by less
than one percent in precision also
better than six sigma
at the upper end of the range 10 minus
the bias of 2.3 divided by imprecision
of 1
better than six sigma at the upper end
of the range now in this case we have a
you know a really ideal scenario
every
level every area of the test is above
six sigma
you might have a different situation you
might find that the low end you have a
lower sigma in the mid
middle of your range the mid control is
got a higher sigma and at the upper end
you have a much higher signal
so you'll have different sigmas being
measured at different levels of the test
and this can cause some
confusion it might cause some anxiety
what do you do when you see you have
different sigmas at different levels
this is why we asked you to
collect the data at medically important
decision levels where is the level
that the control is being run that's
closest to
a decision point that the clinician uses
that makes the most important decision
on the patient
in terms of diagnosis and treatment
if you can identify that take the sigma
closest to that the sigma metric closest
to the most important decision level
that's how we recommend you judge the
test
if you have a very low control but there
aren't any patients there and you have a
low sigma metric
as far as we're concerned that's not as
relevant as a different control level
that might be closer to where patients
actually are
once you've made that decision about
which sigma metric to pay attention to
that's when you come back to these
westgard sigma rules
and if you're at six sigma
you decide uh
the recommendation here is
at six sigma you're not using all the
westgard rules you're just using one
rule
one 3s
and really you're using two control
measurements you're meeting the clear
minimum
that's all you need to do and by the way
that is very low almost no false
rejection
if your method is
five sigma well let's remember that's
excellent
but we're going to expand the
recommendation to three west guard rules
now you add the two 2s now you add the
r4s you're still just making two
measurements it's all done in one run
at four sigma now we need four westgard
rules we have good performance but we
need more
control of more rules to properly
monitor the method
at three sigma and if you remember three
sigma is the minimum acceptable
performance that's when we finally need
all the westgard rules
and we're going to be looking at
increasing the number of measurements
that we have to make
in the most simple version we would be
saying make six measurements instead of
two or three
and so you can see
with three sigma
we need a lot more rules we need a lot
more measurements
and we'll see later we'll actually we
should probably even run qc more often
this is why the minimum level of
performance is not ideal
because it requires much more effort
from us
and if it's below three sigma
well the west guards have run out of
rules and now we would need you yes use
all the westgard rules run as many
controls
as you can afford run as frequently as
you can
afford but think about other things you
could do are there non-statistical
techniques average of normals that you
could adopt that would help you in this
process can you actually improve
imprecision or reduce bias is this
method so poor maybe you should move it
to a different instrument maybe you
should switch instruments when you have
below three sigma quality when you have
fairness level quality you need to make
some changes
and now let's talk about this qc
frequency i've sort of flirted with it
but i haven't told you
any details
you see frequency pretty much is
governed by what i would call a
planet-based qc frequency that is we run
it
once
every revolution of the planet the
planet rotates every 24 hours thus we
run our qc every 24 hours
is there a relationship to
the good
of the process to the rotational speed
of our planet not really this is just a
compliance
for just meeting regulations
sometimes
there is an increased
maybe
two or three times a day once every
eight hours it might
match with how often we have different
shifts
so you know we're we're not basing it on
the planet now we're basing it on our
personnel
and then those of you in the point of
care
uh uh area you know that there is also
this once a month or once a
move a qc policy called iqcp and that is
literally lunacy
once per month running qc
that's inadequate and you might be
howling about
it where we should really
focus our qc frequency is around the
idea of patient risk patient-based qc
frequency
patient-based qc frequency which is also
has to be
performance-based that is we know how
good the test needs to be we know how
well our instrument performs and those
two things drive how often we need to
run qc
and this brings us back to our
registration question
we asked you this before as you signed
up for this webinar
and we saw that
about half of you
run qc just once a day
a little under a quarter run it twice a
day and a little
uh lesser than that is running once per
shift which
could be two or three times a day really
depends on the operational schedule of
the laboratory
so again that's the conventional
response running once a day
when we match that up with the global
trends
we see 27
again almost a quarter
twice a day
uh
you know a
just a slim majority similar to your
answers are running once a day
and a little under 20 running three
times a day
and thankfully
only one point six percent and mostly
those are point of care users are
lunatics
the data driven way to qc frequency
is to base it on your sigma
so if we have three sigma we should be
running our qc every 45 patient samples
and this probably
sounds a bit shocking those of you who
know your patient volumes realize if you
had a three sigma process you would have
to spend a lot more on controls you
really don't want to do that so you
would prefer to have
a process where you had maybe four sigma
and now you're running
every 200 patient samples and that for
many
small laboratories starts to
match their daily reality
if you're high volume where you really
need the
um five sigma tests because now you can
wait
until 450 patient samples go by before
you need to run qc again
and if you're one of those high-powered
massive core laboratories or reference
laboratories
you want six sigma because at six sigma
you can go a thousand patient samples
before you need to run qc again
so you can see that the the sigma
really
builds up
in terms of qc frequency the better you
get
the
the fewer qc you will have to run
and this brings me to
our
things that will also force you to run
qc maybe more than you needed to
mathematically
even if we find out you could run qc
only once per thousand but if you only
run 300 in a day
and then when the next day starts the
clock starts over and clea says you've
got to run qc once a day
another thing that will
force you to run qc perhaps more often
than your sigma does is your
manufacturer's instructions if your
manufacturer says there's a startup
procedure you need to run qc at the
beginning of every day or every certain
number of x hours you have to do that
even if the mathematical
advice is running less frequently
low volume labs if you have a you have a
test where you're only running 100
150 tests a day but it's a six sigma
method well you can't
space out and say well now i only have
to run once a week because
your volume
uh your volume shorts out and then your
clock starts again in 24 hours
another thing you should take into
account is what's your realistic ability
to recover
from a failure
if you could go a thousand if the math
says
you could go a thousand patient samples
but your ability to retest
or recall or make corrections
to a number of test results is not one
thousand then you're going to have to
keep your qc frequency
shorter than what the mass tells you
another thing that will come into play
is your institutional tolerance for risk
if our recommendations reduce your qc
frequency but your risk management
department is not happy with that
you're going to have to go with what
your risk managers are telling you
and finally there's your psychological
well-being can you sleep at night
if we reduce your qc down to
once per thousand
if that's not going to make you if
you're not going to be comfortable with
that we're not going to force you this
is an
option
now obviously if you are comfortable
with it
if you have
the the volume that would support being
able to go once per
1000 patient specimens
and you're still meeting all your
manufacturer instructions and the clear
regulations
then
running qc at that frequency is probably
going to be
lower than where you were
and we'll give you that opportunity
again to save some money and be more
efficient
let's start to wrap up uh
why did we call this unconventional qc
because we want to break conventions
the conventional way the common wisdom
the most common way of doing qc
is you run it for compliance only you're
running the 2sd
control limits or you're running all the
west guard rules
you're repeating controls you're going
double or nothing or you're
recalibrating
or you're feeling rotten because you
have to chase all of these ghosts
and if you're refusing to make these
changes
if you're refusing even to consider the
idea of changing your qc
please recognize that this is not a
sustainable way to run a lab
you have constant pressure to find
savings constant pressure to
make the most of your scarce resources
and your scarcest resource is your tech
time
you're going to continue to have
problems finding staff
that's
there's no in infusion of new talent
coming on the horizon
so figure out how can you free up more
hours for your staff to be able to meet
the increasing demands
if you have a lot of staff who are
pulling their hair
out
staring at control charts
that's not a great use of their time
and it's time to become unconventional
the unconventional conclusion i want you
to reach
re-examine what you're doing
and design your qc don't accept some
default that was set 10 20 30 years ago
reduce your controls
reduce your rules reduce your
measurements when possible
choose your qc rules
to minimize false rejection and maximize
error detection
that's what the westgard sigma rules
will help you do
you calculate that analytical sigma
metric
you implement your westgard sigma rules
that allows you again reduce your rules
reduce your controls reduce your
measurements your control costs go down
your consumption of mana of manufacturer
reagent and supplies goes down your
troubleshooting costs go down
and i leave at the very last
recommendation the consideration of
changing your qc frequency i realize for
most labs that is a stretch it's hard to
consider
it's a challenge
um that's okay if if you can do all the
changes and rules and controls and
measurements first that'll get you a
great amount of savings
um
changing your qc frequency may be
something that you postpone until
you're in a better place and you're more
uh
you have
more of the bandwidth to consider the
mathematics and align
the recommendations with the realities
of your operations
and then lastly i just want to talk
about a program that we offer
that
gives protocols and training on the
application of all these sigma metrics
we call it the sigma metric verification
of performance program
we have laboratories all over the world
where they have taken training for their
staff they have adapted their
qms
they have benchmarked their quality and
then made these changes
you can see more than
uh 75 different examples on the website
of labs
that have benchmarked the quality on the
sigma scale and the changes they have
made
and with that we reach the end of our
formal presentation and we can begin to
open up
to questions a live q a and it does look
like we have
more than a dozen questions but i do
encourage you
to keep the questions coming in because
if i don't answer it right now
we will answer all of them and post them
on the westgard website you'll be able
to see
your question answered on the website
later
so with that again i want to thank
technopath and lab roots for
making this event happen
happy that so many hundreds of you were
able to join i hope you have some
questions
and we'll launch right into that now
thank you stan
for your informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for let's get started
our first question is
how do you determine your six sigma
metric
if there is not a total allowable error
value mandated by
etc
all right that is a great question um
obviously
that comes up there are tests
uh usually the
performance specification
uh that happens after the the test has
been introduced so if we have a lot of
new tests on the market it's going to
take a while to figure out how good
those tests need to be
there's
a very rich body of work in the
literature about trying to establish
performance specifications and
the general framework is
start by looking at the clinical use of
the test
see how
changes in the results will change
outcomes or change diagnoses
and then you work that interval back
call that a clinical decision interval
and you're going to work that back into
the laboratory to figure out how you as
a laboratory
and
keep your error small enough so that you
won't change
you know someone who's sick to someone
who's normal or vice versa
so
while there may not be formal
specifications you can always go to your
clinicians go look at the use of the
test and determine it directly yourself
you are empowered to use your
professional judgment to set an
allowable total error if no one exists
anywhere else
okay thank you
next question
where do i find the clia guidelines you
mentioned
excellent so the proficiency testing
criteria of clia they're in the federal
register so you could type in all those
terms i just
mentioned on google and you eventually
will find the list there
on the westgard website so westgard.com
we have a quality requirements section
we list not only the clia goals
we list really bach we list rcpa we have
a a consolidated table where we try and
put a number of different resources from
all over the world into one table so you
can see you can compare the different
goals across the global resources and we
even in our sigma vp program we make a
recommendation you know if there are a
dozen different
specifications for glucose around the
world which one do we believe is the
appropriate one for tests for
laboratories
okay great thank you
um our next question is if pure qc data
is used to determine bias
what is the ideal set of stats
our lab cumulative versus peer
cumulative or our monthly versus peer
cumulative
our monthly
uh
with that's the end of the question i'm
sorry or our monthly versus peer
cumulative
that is a very good question because
it's so it's so well detailed you know
in a peer group program you have that
monthly set of data and then you have
your cumulative
now in general
if you look at
all your qc
guidelines if you look at the clsi c24
which is your recommendations for best
practices they're going to say what you
want is three to six months of
cumulative data for your mean and your
standard deviation so ideally we would
like to follow that when we go to sigma
metrics we want more than one month of
data
so we would like to do
the cumulative comparison and that might
be covering two months it might be
covering six months
but that long-term performance data um
that gives us the best picture of
overall how is the method performing so
we have a best our best picture of bias
by doing a comparison of your observed
cumulative mean versus the pure
cumulative mean
okay thank you
next question if different levels on the
same analyte have varying sigma levels
is it acceptable to have different rule
sets for each level
that's a an important question and i
i would say if you decide to do
different qc rules
on different control levels
that way madness lies
okay you will go crazy if you have to
look at each level and employ a whole
different set of qc rules
so
uh most labs
they run they choose one qc design for
all the levels whether it's two or three
levels on a test they all get the same
qc design and
um
i would guess that most software is
implemented that way i haven't seen the
granular control of being able to plot
your
different rules on different levels of a
qc test
it might exist but
in my mind it's better to figure out
let's do one sigma metric for the whole
test
and therefore one qc design for the
whole test
okay thank you
um
next question when comparing measurement
uncertainty
does it have to compare with t-a-e
uh that is uh
well let's say i you may have noticed
that i did not mention measurement
uncertainty in the entirety of my
presentation
and for those of you in the us you you
may also have noticed that you can
operate a laboratory without
pretty much ever having to encounter
measurement uncertainty
the total allowable error in all of
those performance specifications they
were created
with the idea of
making
sigma metrics or qc choices total
allowable errors were created not for
measurement uncertainty
nevertheless those
total allowable errors and there are so
many resources that are built that way
um
the
proponents of measurement uncertainty
have started to borrow
the total allowable error limits and use
them in some way to compare against your
measurement uncertainty
there is a what's called a permissible
measurement uncertainty and that is
uh i am not making this up that is
abbreviated as pu
and your pu
uh you're not supposed to exceed your pu
with your actual
measurement uncertainty or your mu what
i call the mu
the mu should not be bigger than the pu
there are relatively few
specifications the
the number of pu's out there is very
small
they only came out with a few set of pus
this year
so
overall
my advice about measurement uncertainty
is stay in compliance if you have to
create mu
if you have to move do it
but most labs that i have encountered
they calculate their mood
they show it to an inspector the
inspector says great
and then they put that move away and
they never use it
it is
something that your iso 15189 requires
but in practical
terms it's almost never used
theoretically it would be great to use
with your clinicians
to be able to say this is the result and
this is the uncertainty around the
result
and then the clinician could make a
decision saying well the number is here
but it could it's really in a cloud
around there
and i have to be careful if that cloud
looks too big i shouldn't make any big
decisions
those of you who enjoy reporting
results to clinicians you can guess
that a lot of clinicians don't take
kindly to being told here's your number
but it's not really where i told you
it's in this cloud of uncertainty
the clinician often will respond no tell
me what the number is
and so it it's often like a confidence
interval uh we can report confidence
intervals but usually the clinicians
ignore them or find them unhelpful
and that's what you're getting an
unvarnished
opinion
on
measurement uncertainty from a westgard
and i realize that that might be a
contrarian
perspective we have an unconventional
perspective on mu
okay thank you
um looks like we have time for one more
question
to calculate six sigma values
can we use the biased data we obtained
with a single sample in the external
quality control program
which will be
the bias of the previous month's result
for all three levels of internal quality
control until the next
inaccuracy data come
all right that brings us back to bias
and if we're not using the pure
comparison uh software program
obviously external quality assessment or
proficiency testing it really is
designed to determine your bias
now
the that's the positive of it the
negative of proficiency testing is in
the u.s
you might only do it two or three times
a year and then you might not do that
many samples
you know you may not have that many
samples each time you're doing a
challenge
so there is a downside of course to
having fewer data points to determine
your bias but if that's the way if
that's the only way you can determine
bias
my opinion is you should go ahead and do
that
it's not a great amount of data but it's
your only data unbiased you should go
ahead and use it
if you would find
more comfort and more
uh i would say there's more
robust stability in a peer group mean
versus observed meme
determination of bias i would encourage
you to use that
okay great thank you
um do you have sten do you have any
final comments for our audience
well again i want to thank uh so many
hundreds of you who joined us today it
looks like we have more than 50
questions so while i've been able to
answer a handful
we will be answering more and i
encourage you to stay tuned to the
technopath and westgard website for
those following questions
uh you may have seen my last slide said
sten westgard.com
that's my email part of my mission is to
help you
uh so
please feel free to send more questions
to my email address also those will be
in those answers will be included in an
online uh posting later i hope that
you've come away from this feeling like
there are
are some concrete steps that you can
make there are tools that are free
and available for download and use that
will help you on this pathway to
becoming unconventional
to changing how you do qc
getting better at qc and
having fewer rules and fewer
frustrations and fewer controls that you
have to run in this process of qc
i hope you have a good rest of your day
i
of course thank you for all the efforts
you are making in fighting this
global pandemic
[Music]
we've never had a moment that was made
it more clear how important your job is
and the things that you do
really save lives
i am
really proud i feel lucky to be able to
call laboratory professionals my
colleagues
well thank you again stan for your time
today in your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots in
our sponsor technopath clinical
diagnostics usa for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go
i'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time